♪ ♪
>> Raymond: WELCOME BACK TO
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE," NEW YORK'S
NEWEST CONGRESSWOMAN, SOCIALIST
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ, IN
ADDITION TO MEDICARE FOR ALL,
FREE COLLEGE AND A PLAN TO
ABOLISH ICE, THE 29-YEAR-OLD NOW
SAYS SHE WANTS TO TAX THE RICH
TO PAY FOR THE LEFT'S
ENVIRONMENTAL AGENDA KNOWN AS
THE GREEN PLAN.
>> ONCE YOU GET TO THE TIPPY TOP
ON YOUR $10 MILLION, SOMETIMES
YOU SEE TAX RATES AS HIGH AS 60
OR 70%.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN ALL
$10 MILLION ARE TAXED AT AN
EXTREMELY HIGH RATE BUT IT MEANS
AS YOU CLIMB UP THIS LATTER, YOU
SHOULD BE CONTRIBUTING MORE.
>> Raymond: HERE NOW, COREY
LEWANDOWSKI FORMER TRUMP 2016
CAMPAIGN MANAGER AND COAUTHOR OF
THE NEW BOOK TRUMPS ENEMIES --
AND IN NEW YORK CITY PUBLIC
ADVOCATE.
BEFORE I GET YOUR TAKE, HERE ARE
SOME TAXPAYERS REACTIONS.
WATCH.
>> THE 1 PERCENT DOES NEED TO BE
TAXED MORE THAN THEY ARE BUT AT
THE SAME TIME TRUMPS TAX POLICY
IS HELPING THE ECONOMY IN THE
ECONOMY IS GOING WELL.
>> I THINK THAT'S FAIR.
>> AT 70%?
>> I THINK IT SHOULD BE MORE
THAN IT IS.
>> IT'S AT 39% NOW.
>> THE TOP 1%, THAT'S NOT ME.
THERE IS FAIR.
>> SHE DIDN'T ASK THE ONE PER
CENTERS OF HER PARTY WHAT THEY
THINK.
>> Raymond: IS THIS A WINNING
STRATEGY TO TASK UPPER INCOME?
>> INCOME INEQUALITY IS WORSE
THAN IT IS THIS EVER IN AMERICA.
AFTER A WALL STREET CRASH IN
1929, INCOME INEQUALITY WAS NOT
THAT BAD.
NEW YORK CITY IN PARTICULAR
GENERATES MORE WEALTH THAN
ANYONE ON THE PLANET BUT WE HAVE
THE WORST INCOME INEQUALITY, A
LOT OF THAT COMES FROM THE
BILLIONAIRES.
>> Raymond: DOESN'T THIS SAP
OF THE INCENTIVE TO JOIN THE
BILLIONAIRE CLASS, TO STRIVE FOR
THAT, TO BE THE NEXT OPRAH, THE
NEXT BLOOMBERG IT DOESN'T
DEPRIVE YOU OF THAT INITIATIVE,
IF YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
TAXED IN NEW YORK A PLACE THAT
YOU WANT TO RUN, IF YOU TOOK
THIS 70% TAX RATE AND SLAPPED
LOCAL TAXES ON IT, YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT AN 82.7% TAX
BREAK.
>> FOR THE 1% WHO HAVE HAD TAX
BREAKS, HUNDREDS OF TRILLIONS OF
TAX BREAKS WHICH STARVES OUR
HOUSING AND SCHOOLS, OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE, WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT A DECREPIT CITY THAT
GENERATES MORE WEALTH AND IT'S
BECAUSE THE 0.1% ARE NOT PAYING
TAXES.
>> Raymond: THEY ARE PAYING
THEY ARE OPENING NEW BUSINESSES
AND THE ECONOMY -- THE REASON
THE ECONOMY IS EXPLODING --
>> OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE
PAYING FOR IT.
>> AND ANDERSON COOPER CHALLENGE
TO HIS CREDIT CORTEZ.
>> I THINK IT IS ONLY EVER BEEN
RADICALS WHO CHANGE THIS
COUNTRY, ABRAHAM LINCOLN MADE A
RADICAL DECISION TO SIGNED THE
EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION,
FRANKLIN DELANO ROOSEVELT MADE
THE RADICAL DECISION TO EMBARK
ON ESTABLISHING PROGRAMS LIKE
SOCIAL SECURITY, THAT IS
RADICAL.
>> DO YOU CALL YOURSELF A
RADICAL?
>> IF THAT'S WHAT RADICAL MEANS,
CALL ME A RADICAL.
>> SHE'S BEEN IN OFFICE EXACTLY
24 HOURS AND SHE'S COMPARING
HERSELF TO FDR AND JFK AND
LINCOLN.
THERE'S A LONG WAY TO GO BUT
WHAT SHE IS ADVOCATING FOR IS A
TAX RATE OF 83% IN CALIFORNIA,
84, 85% IN NEW YORK CITY TO A
CLOSE PERSONAL FRIENDS LIKE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
THEY ARE THE ONES WHO ARE GOING
TO BE PAYING FOR IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT YOU LIVE IN
ANOTHER UNIVERSE.
>> Raymond: SHE JUST SAID THE
RICH SHOULD PAY 70%.
>> OH, NO, THE RICH HAVE TO PAY
TAXES LIKE OTHER WORKING PEOPLE.
WHAT STOPS WAS BILLIONAIRES FROM
PAYING MORE RIGHT NOW?
THERE'S NOTHING THAT PROHIBITS
THEM FROM PAYING MORE?
WHY CAN'T THEY IF THEY WANT TO.
>> BECAUSE THEY'RE MAKING MONEY
OFF THE BACKS OF WORKING PEOPLE.
>> YOU MEAN LIKE JEFF BEZOS
DOES?
>> YES, LIKE JEFF BEZOS DOES.
>> Raymond: 2.6 MILLION JOBS
ADDED IN THE ENTIRE YEAR, YOU
HAD WAGES GOING UP 3.2%, ROSA
DeLAURO IN CONNECTICUT IS UP
FOR HIKING TAXES, IS THIS WHAT
WE NEED MORE OF AN MIGHT THIS
THE ECONOMIC RENAISSANCE --
CORY, YOU FIRST.
>> DONALD TRUMP HAS CREATED MORE
JOBS IN THE MANUFACTURING SPACE
IN TWO YEARS THAN BARACK OBAMA
DID IN TWO TERMS.
IF YOU RAISE TAXES ON PEOPLE WHO
ARE CREATING JOBS ARE GOING TO
STOP CREATING JOBS.
IF YOU RAISE THE INTEREST RATE
THEY WILL STOP BORROWING MONEY,
THAT HAS A TRICKLE-DOWN EFFECT.
THE TAX POLICIES CUTTING TAXES
FOR EVERYONE ACROSS THE BOARD
HAS WORKED -- IF YOU DON'T
BELIEVE ME LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
OF THE UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR
HISPANICS AND AFRICAN-AMERICANS
IN OUR COUNTRY, THEY ARE AT
RECORD LOWS BECAUSE OF THE JOB
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES.
>> Raymond: I'M A LATINO, THE
HISPANIC NUMBERS ARE AT THE
BOTTOM HISTORIC LOWS OF
UNEMPLOYMENT.
YOU HAVE MORE WORKPLACE
PARTICIPATION THAN EVER BEFORE.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THAT, IS THE
ECONOMY WORKING?
>> IT'S NOT THE ECONOMY WORKING.
WAGES ARE LOWER THAN EVER AND
YOU DON'T HAVE BENEFITS.
PEOPLE ARE WORKING TWO JOBS BUT
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO MAKE THE
RENT -- RENT IS HIGHER THAN IT'S
EVER BEEN AND WAGES ARE LOWER.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE BENEFITS --
MAYBE YOU SHOULD READ JEFFREY
SACHS.
WHEN YOU BREAK YOUR ARM AND YOU
SUDDENLY ARE AND CORRUPT BECAUSE
YOU DON'T HAVE HEALTH CARE, THAT
IS WHY WHEN YOU PAY INTO
MEDICARE, IT PREVENTS YOU FROM
GOING INTO BANKRUPTCY.
IT'S NOT JUST THAT WAGES NEED TO
BE HIGHER, PEOPLE ARE WORKING
MORE AND THEN THEY ARE GOING
BANKRUPT.
>> Raymond: CRIME IS DOWN,
UNEMPLOYMENT IS DOWN, THESE ARE
WONDERFUL THINGS.
VERY QUICKLY, I'VE GOT TO GET TO
ONE MORE.
>> IF THIS TOOK PLACE UNDER THE
OBAMA ECONOMY YOU BE PRAISING
HIM AS THE GREATEST PRESIDENT
SINCE LINCOLN -- SHE ALREADY DID
THAT.
BERNIE SANDERS WANTS TO ADD 2.2%
TO THE PAYROLL TAX AMONGST OTHER
THINGS.
>> TO GIVE PEOPLE HEALTH CARE?
>> Raymond: I WANT TO QUIET
FOR A MOMENT SO YOU CAN FIGHT
OVER SOMETHING ELSE, LET'S GET
YOUR THOUGHTS OVER
HILLARY CLINTON MEETING WITH A
POSSIBLE 2020 DEMOCRATS BECAUSE
HER OWN CAMPAIGNS WENT SO
SWIMMINGLY.
SHE MET WITH KAMALA HARRIS,
CORY BOOKER ELIZABETH WARREN
ALONG OTHERS, WHY ARE DEMOCRATS
COMING TO KISS THIS WOMAN'S
RING?
36% APPROVAL RATING.
>> IF YOU WANT TO MEET
DONALD TRUMP YOU HAVE TO HAVE A
WORKING PEOPLE'S MOVEMENT.
TOO MANY DEMOCRATS THE MAJORITY
OF STATUS QUO DEMOCRATS ARE
WORRIED ABOUT RAISING MONEY AND
WHAT DOES SECRETARY CLINTON
HAVE?
A LOT OF DONORS AND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THEY THINK
WILL GET THEM TO WIN AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
IF I'M SUPPORTING BERNIE SANDERS
BECAUSE HE IS A MOVEMENT OF
MILLIONS OF WORKING ACTIVISTS
ACROSS AMERICA WHO ARE READY TO
FIGHT AND HAVE BEEN FIGHTING FOR
THINGS LIKE MEDICARE FOR ALL,
CANCELLATION OF STUDENT DEBT AND
A GREEN NEW DEAL.
>> Raymond: SANDERS DID AWAKEN
A GRASSROOTS MOVEMENT.
IF I WERE ONE OF THESE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES I WOULD BE
BEATING A PATH TO
MICHELLE OBAMA'S HOUSE AND
BECOMING HER BEST FRIEND GIVEN
THOSE BOOK SALES.
YOUR REACTION TO ALL OF THESE
DEMOCRATS KISSING HILLARY'S RIN
RING?
>> BERNIE SANDERS HAD THE SECOND
LARGEST CROWD OF ANY CANDIDATES
BEHIND DONALD TRUMP, HE CLEARLY
HAD A MOVEMENT BEHIND HIM.
THE SYSTEM WAS RIGGED AGAINST
HIM.
THE ONLY RUSSIANS THAT WERE
INVOLVED IN THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN
WHEN SHE TOOK $5 MILLION FROM A
LAW FIRM AND GAVE IT TO A
BRITISH SPY TO PUT TOGETHER THE
DOSSIER, THAT'S YOUR PARTY THAT
DID THAT, LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS -- ANY
CANDIDATE THAT IS LOOKING FOR
HILLARY CLINTON'S ENDORSEMENT IS
GOING TO LOSE.
SHE RAN A TERRIBLE CAMPAIGN,
TERRIBLE OPERATION IN PLACE AND
SHE LOST A CAMPAIGN THAT EVERY
PUNDIT THOUGHT SHE SHOULD HAVE
WON.
>> Raymond: I WANT TO SHOW MY
PEOPLE THIS.
HOT OFF THE LIVE STREAM BEER
DRINKING DOWN TO EARTH TALK WITH
REAL AMERICAN SENATOR ELIZABETH
WARREN IS SPENDING A WEEKEND
WITH VOTERS IN IOWA AND THERE'S
A DRINKING THEME HERE, SHE'S IN
A SALOON TONIGHT -- HE SAID THIS
JUST A MOMENT AGO.
>> I'M NOT A CAREER POLITICIAN,
I NEVER THOUGHT I'D RUN FOR
ABOUT OFFICE.
WHAT PULLS ME INTO THE FIGHT AS
I GOT A CHANCE AS A KID.
THAT CHANCE WAS BECAUSE
TAXPAYERS INVESTED IN PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
>> Raymond: WHO IS BUYING
THIS?
I'LL START WITH YOU.
>> YOU KNOW THE OLD ADAGE IS THE
POLITICIAN YOU WANT TO HAVE A
BEER WITH, THAT'S WHY
GEORGE W. BUSH WON AGAINST
AL GORE.
I HAVE A SIPPY CUP OF WINE IN
THE BACK.
>> ELIZABETH WARREN IS A
TERRIBLE CANDIDATE AT TERRIBLE
LAUNCH SO FAR, SHE LAUNCHED A
TIME WHEN NO ONE IS PAYING
ATTENTION, SHE TOOK A DNA TEST
TO APPROVE THAT SHE IS NO MORE
NATIVE AMERICAN THAN I AM, I'M
NOT NATIVE AMERICAN AND I'M